okay i'm thankful for getting this
opportunity to come and share what we
are doing at the University of that
Islam in Tanzania
just ok
okay first of all I would like to start
by introducing the universal answer is
to put the discussion or my short
presentation in perspective are the
universal Islam is young in the
international level but at the national
level is the oldest university
established in 61 this is the year when
tanganyika got independence from britain
and therefore the university actually
was part of independence so it is there
for caring are carrying all we say the
task and expectations for a new
university in a new country in 63 it was
a quality of University of East Africa
so we had a University of East Africa
and in 70 it became a full-fledged
University when we started we were quite
modest the university would see it
started with 14 students and there was
only one female student in that year but
today we have almost 30 we have about 30
students and about thirty percent 35 or
whatever is actually female so we have
expanded that and we started in one
college but today we have three colleges
we started one University today we have
over 45 universities in Tanzania etc etc
so that is showing some development now
i'm showing also some pictures of our
environment just my message was to show
that our conservation issues are not
only on culture but also on environment
and for those who have been to dallas
LOM they would
appreciate the fact that you get to the
University you see it's completely
different environment although we are
within the city of Jerusalem the care of
heritage in Tanzania fall within three
main institution of course at the
general level we know that the
custodians are the community or the
public in general but at the government
level we have the Department of
Antiquities we have the National Museum
and the university of dallas lab kind of
surprising that why university of dallas
LOM this is because of the history i
toldya apart we have so many
universities but the university of allah
islam has that advantage the antiquities
deals with issues of policies and the
museum as we know deals more with the
portable materia conservation and
curation and the university with
research and all other issues as
narrated there but what is important and
what I want to bring forth to you is
that the role of the university as a
model because yes we are the ones who
are training experts to work in the
antiquities and those who work at the
Museum and other places where heritage
experts work but what do we do we have
ourselves the obligation especially as
the first and oldest university to show
the way how to do things better and we
have tried actually in terms of training
experts as we see that we have about
forty nine percent of experts in the
antiquities alumni of the University of
that Islam but 25
from museum from the University and even
within the department of heritage and
archaeology at the University almost
everyone of course we are very few we
are about 6 16 but all of us have at
least one degree from the University of
Jerusalem either be a or a way or PhD so
that is something that we have done in
the training but it's not just for
Tanzania but we are also training
experts in the neighboring there are
countries because the university of ram
has the way i would say the most sound
and comprehensive program in heritage
studies archaeology and heritage
management basically but we also have
causes in conservation neurology them
studies etc etc now in terms of shown
what apart from training we also went a
step further to construct a museum and
this was not something easy given that
our media resources in the developing
countries but we managed to prepare a
proposal for word bank and they gave us
funds to construct this museum and it's
just newly opened we have not yet even
started displaying permanent exhibitions
we have temporal right now but it is the
step and whenever we say like get into
discussion with people in the Heritage
Secretary the country they look at us as
people who really are there for
practical work rather than just theories
in the classroom apart from that so we
also
another step further in terms of
conservation one example is we have one
structure called the it crew Mahal this
was constructed in the late 60s the main
function of this whole had been apart
from a general discussion for and say
like lectures for students at the
University this whole acted so much for
the liberation of southern Africa many
countries from southern Africa coming to
Tanzania in the 70s 80s when they were
looking for independence this is the
place where they would come and give
their presentations so it had that kind
of international role and for that
reason even the government did actually
give it the status of having it in the
National bill of our currency so we
decided the university this is an
important structure we need to gather
teach so that it gets a status of
conservation and it was granted last
year and so that again was a kind of
demonstration as a university what we
can do in terms of conservation of
heritage another example is the
conservation of intangible heritage in
this case indigenous languages are
tanzania has about a hundred and twenty
ethnic groups and therefore these are
actually divided in the line of
languages and so we have this taken the
task to conserve these languages we have
a common language a lingua franca this
is kiswahili and which is a kind of
combination of these Bantu languages
plus Arabic
but then the local languages are going
away with the emphasis on a case for him
so the university of dallas alarm
decided to take lead in in this aspect
and finally we also have we also
contribute when it comes to different
projects the government would like in
the heritage sector we go there as
consultants okay but we do have
challenges in this undertaking must
accept of course the list could be much
bigger but i decided just to talk about
to one is lack of funding which is quite
a common zone in the developing
countries of course even developed
countries but so we do have a shortage
of staff said we are 16 we would like to
have more solid we expand our programs
also currently as i said the museum is
there but we are so much struggling and
we are trying to find sources of funds
so that we really make it look like a
good university museum we also need to
expand in terms of programs of training
but also the second what i would
consider to be a serious problem is this
the negative attitude the government has
on humanistic and in this case
conservation and heritage areas and this
is not unique to tanzania I mean from
yesterday though I came late but I could
see this being resonated here and there
so we also have that kind of problem as
a result to find that there is low
student enrollment because we go by
loans for higher education in Tanzania
and loans are given to
stem students and not art or humanistic
students so that is one of the problem
why we are having this kind of phones
okay so in conclusion I would say yes
that we have a lot of heritage in
Tanzania as scholars in the area we have
tried to do our best but our
philosophies that what we have interns
in here is actually for the world and we
also believe what you all here have in
your countries are also our task in
Tanzania to help assist so what we can
say and what I can say is that where
what we need to do is work together so
that and this is actually fortunately
the motor we have in our pub state we
unite for our heritage thank you very
much